I'm curious I don't know if you can
speak this but what's the reaction from
the islands around it I mean like do the
other communities
kind of pair at the same lines as you
know Lahaina did the best they could or
are they critical of how uh Lanahan
managed the fires so it's actually very
it's a very polarizing issue out there
uh they most people even a lot of the
the
democrat-leaning people that I've spoken
with out there are like this is a this
was a catastrophic failure of government
you know the people that they voted for
they have totally lost faith in these
people uh these people got very
comfortable the mayor especially uh and
the governor of Hawaii both both very
liberal Democrats they got very
comfortable out there they thought
because it's a very blue State uh and
even the people that are typically their
voter base are now questioning whether
or not that's a that's a good decision
because they've gotten way too
authoritarian
and there's no sign of that going back